I want to actually get you to understand a little bit more about gradients, and
I'm going to use this example.
Remember, again,
gradient magnitude is this and the angle comes from this equation here.
This was simply the derivative, in x.
This is the image for this one.
This is the derivative in y.
This is the magnitude, the whole value of this thing.
Of course, the brightness and stuff like that is kind of compromised because we
scaling it up from between 0 and 255, but this basically now starts showing you
exactly where the gradient magnitude is for this image.
If you notice the zebra all of the changes anywhere are now visible here.
This image is the gradient angle theta.
So at any point it basically says, where is the direction of the gradient.
Now this is extremely hard to visualize and understand very carefully, so
what we'll actually do is come up with another way of looking at it.
One way of looking at this is basically being able to now look at
all the gradients, and drawing a arrow in the direction of
where the gradient increases, and also giving that vector.
Because if you remember, in essence, this is the magnitude of the vector and
this is the direction where the great intensity is, and
the direction of the gradient.
I've shown this with the zebra image here.
Of course it's hard to see, so let's zoom in.
Zooming in now starts showing you the gradient vectors and developmental detail.
Even zooming in more you can now see what I was referring to.
Now note again, this is something that was important, that the magnitude and
the direction of the gradient is this way.
However, the edge that we want is this way.
Direction this way, edge this way.
Similarly, there is another edge here.
And the direction for this one is also this way.
So that's an important thing for us to look at.
And use that to be able to kind of model these things.
Of course, here we're looking for just the absolute directions and
stuff like that.
Even more close up you can see the edge and the red directions and
the magnitudes of the gradient.
Let me show you this thing in a different way.